una llamada que estaba pendiente desde
hace semanas y ha sido bienvenida tanto
por la Unión Europea como Estados Unidos
siempre con sus matistas también ha sido
bienvenida desde el kremlin Aunque ellos
dicen que si bien cada país es soberano
de hacer todas sus gestiones
diplomáticas dicen que esa llamada
operación especial como ellos llaman a
esa Guerra y a esa invasión que lanzaron
el año pasado en Ucrania tiene que
cumplir sus objetivos para el país en un
primer momento Esa llamada ha dado sus
resultados Ucrania ha anunciado que ha
designado un embajador en Beijing un
puesto que estaba de vacante y Desde
allí se ha anunciado el envío de una
misión que tiene como misión Buscar
estrategias para una salida negociada a
esta guerra que en este momento
recordemos que en Ucrania se está
esperando esa contraofensiva que para
esta Primavera Aunque el clima sigue
siendo bastante malo y siguen esperando
las armas suficientes para comenzarlas
Ucrania siempre ha dicho que ellos
primero que todo necesitan recuperar
esos territorios que fueron invadidos
por Rusia no solamente desde hace 14
meses con el inicio de esa invasión a
gran escala sino desde el 2014 pero
muchos creen que ya la intervención de
China el gran Aliado de Moscú
actualmente puede ser un primer paso
para buscar alternativas a una salud
negociaciones próximas en esta guerra